BRIAN:  LET’S BRING IN LOUISIANA
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY, WE SHOW
THE WIDE SHOT OF NEW ORLEANS A
SHORT TIME AGO.
SENATOR WELCOME.
I TELL YOU, IT’S KIND OF DISTURB
ING BUT IT’S ALL TOO
FAMILIAR OUR FLIGHT TEAM, OUR
DRONE TEAM WAS ABLE TO CAPTURE
PEOPLE JUST RUNNING FULL SPRINT,
ONE OF WHICH TWO GUYS WERE IN
HANDCUFFS, ACROSS OUR BORDER.
WHY IS THERE NOT, WHY CAN’T
THERE BE A BIPARTISAN SENSE OF
OUTRAGE EVERYWHERE IN SEEING
THIS?
>> WELL, THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY HAS ANNOUNCED
THAT THE BORDER IS CLOSED, BUT
THEY LIED LIKE THEY BREATHE.
I MEAN, I DON’T MEAN TO BE UGLY
BUT THEY LIE LIKE THEY BREATHE.
WHEN I HEARD THE SECRETARY SAY
THE BORDER IS CLOSED, MY MIND
WENT BACK TO THAT IMAGE OF
PRESIDENT CLINTON LOOKING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE EYE
SAYING THAT I DID NOT HAVE SEX
WITH THAT WOMAN.
WE KNOW HOW THAT TURNED OUT.
I’VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
IF YOU BELIEVE THE BORDER IS
CLOSED, YOU BELIEVE IN THE TOOTH
FAIRY, THE EASTER
BUNNY AND THAT JIMMY HOFFA DIED
OF NATURAL CAUSES.
WE’LL HAVE 2 MILLION PEOPLE COME
IN TO THE UNITED STATES THIS
YEAR, ILLEGALLY, THANKS TO
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY ARE,
EXCEPT THEY’RE COMING FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALMOST COMPLETELY HALTED ANY
KIND OF DEPORTATION OF PEOPLE
ALREADY HERE ILLEGALLY.
AMERICA HAS BECOME ONE GIANT
SANCTUARY CITY, AND THE SAME OF
ALL OF THIS IS IS THAT IN
ADDITION TO VIOLATING THE LAW
AND BEING DANGEROUS, IT
UNDERMINES LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
MOST AMERICANS SUPPORT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
I DO.
WE WELCOME A MILLION PEOPLE TO
COME INTO OUR COUNTRY.
BRIAN:  YOU’LL NEVER GET REFORM
AS LONG AS THIS IS HAPPENING,
EVER.
CANADA IS SEALED, THE NORTHERN
BORDER IS SEALED, THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS CHAOS.
ROMAINE YANKEESES ARE COMING
THROUGH.
>> WELL, PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
PUT AROUND HIM, I KNOW HE’S A
NICE GUY, HE IS A NICE GUY, I’VE
TALKED TO HIM BUT THE PEOPLE
HE’S PUT AROUND HIM ARE EXTREME
LY RADICAL.
I MEAN, THEY CAN LIVE IN CRAZY
TOWN.
THEY NEED AN  EXORCIST.
THESE FOLKS REALLY BELIEVE THAT
VETTING PEOPLE AT THE BORDER IS
RACIST.
THEY THINK THAT UNLIKE ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD, WE ARE SUPPOSED TO
JUST WELCOME ANYBODY WHO WANTS
TO COME IN WITHOUT ASKING ANY
QUESTIONS.
BRIAN:  CRAZY.
>> THAT JUST, AMERICAN PEOPLE
DON’T SUPPORT THAT, AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN KNOWS IT, SO
THAT’S WHY I SAY SO MANY OF HIS
PEOPLE LIE LIKE THEY BREATHE.
AINSLEY: YOU MENTIONED THE DHS
SECRETARY MAYORKAS TALKING ABOUT
THE BORDER BEING CLOSED WE PUT
TOGETHER A MONTAGE OF HIM SAYING
THAT OVER AND OVER.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE ARE ELEVATING OUR
MESSAGING SO THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS DO KNOW THAT
THEY CANNOT COME TO THE BORDER,
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
>> PRECISELY THAT.
>> THE MESSAGE IS QUITE CLEAR.
DO NOT COME.
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
WE’VE BEEN IN THAT.
AINSLEY: THE BORDER IS NOT
SECURE YOU CAN LOOK AT ALL THIS
VIDEO.
WE PLAY IT ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
DAY OF MORE GROUPS COMING
THROUGH.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, I KNOW THE SECRETARY.
LOOK, HERE IS WHAT D.C. IS ALL
ABOUT.
THE THING THAT MOST PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON D.C. WANT IS TO KEEP
THEIR JOBS, AND I’M SURE THE
SECRETARY WANTS TO KEEP HIS
JOB, AND I’M SURE HE’S BEEN TOLD
BY THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE TO JUST
SAY OKAY, THE BORDER IS CLOSED,
AND SO MANY PEOPLE AROUND
PRESIDENT BIDEN BELIEVE THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE MORONS
AND THAT THEY WILL
JUST BELIEVE WHATEVER THEY SEE
ON TELEVISION AND THEY
AREN’T MORONS AND THEY DON’T
BELIEVE IT BECAUSE IT’S NOT TRUE
, AND I THINK THEY KNOW THAT
, BUT THIS JUST SHOWS YOU
THE CONTEMPT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAVE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STEVE: AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE
SHOWING THOSE IMAGES FROM OUR
DRONE TEAM, THE ADMINISTRATION
MAY SAY IT’S CLOSED BUT CLEARLY,
IT IS WIDE OPEN.
SENATOR, I KNOW ON CAPITOL HILL
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY RIGHT
NOW SEEMS TO BE TO TRY TO GET
FOR THE REPUBLICANS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
YOUR SUGGESTION IS ABOUT A THIRD
OF THEIR LATEST.
THERE SEEMS TO, HOWEVER, HAVE
BEEN A LITTLE COMPROMISE,
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT CAME BACK,
HE LOPPED ABOUT A HALF A
TRILLION DOLLARS OFF OF IT AND
THIS IS WHAT ONE OF HIS SENIOR
ADVISORS SAID ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, ALONG WITH
BERNIE SANDERS, AND WHERE IT
COULD GO NEXT.
>> HE WANTS A DEAL, HE WANTS IT
SOON, BUT IS THERE MEANINGFUL
NEGOTIATIONS TAKING PLACE IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER, HE’S WILLING
TO LET THAT PLAY OUT, BUT AGAIN,
HE WILL NOT LET INACTION BE THE
ANSWER AND WHEN HE GETS TO
THE POINT WHERE IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT IS INEVITABLE, YOU’LL SEE
HIM CHANGE COURSE.
>> WE WOULD LIKE BIPARTISANSHIP
BUT I DON’T THINK WE HAVE A
SERIOUSNESS ON THE PART OF THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP TO
ADDRESS THE MAJOR CRISIS FACING
THIS COUNTRY AND IF THEY’RE NOT
COMING FORWARD WE’VE GOT TO GO
FORWARD ALONE.
STEVE: SO IN OTHER WORDS BERNIE
SANDERS WANTS TO BLOW OFF THE
SYSTEM, DO A RECONCILIATION,
HOWEVER, AS WE HEARD FROM THE
FIRST ADVICE JOE BIDEN IS
WILLING TO CHANGE COURSE IF THE
REPUBLICANS DON’T DEAL.
THEIR OFFER IS STILL THREE TIMES
MORE THAN WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
WILLING TO DO, SO HE’S GOING TO
HAVE TO CHANGE COURSE, ISN’T HE?
>> WELL, AS SOON AS PRESIDENT
BIDEN PUTS AN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL IN FRONT OF ME, I WILL
CONSIDER IT, BUT RIGHT NOW, HIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, HE’S
BASICALLY ASKING TO BUY A CAR TO
GET THE CUPHOLDERS, ONLY ABOUT
FIVE, MAYBE 10% OF HIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE REST OF
IT IS THE GREEN NEW DEAL, THE
FEDERAL TAKEOVER OF CHILD
CARE, AND REPIRATIONS.
NOW IF THE PRESIDENT WANTS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, WE CAN
PUT ONE TOGETHER WITH OUR
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS IN THE SENATE
VERY QUICKLY.
IT’LL BE SIX TO $800 MILLION,
IT’LL BE ROADS, BRIDGES, PORTS,
SEWER, WATER, BROADBAND.
WE CAN TELL HIM HOW TO PAY FOR
IT BY REPURPOSING SOME OF
THE CORONAVIRUS MONEY, AND BY
SCRUBBING THE FEDERAL BUDGET A
LITTLE BIT, BUT HE DOESN’T WANT
TO DO THAT, AND I DON’T THINK
THE WHITE HOUSE IS REALLY
INTERESTED IN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL.
THEY’RE MORE INTERESTED IN A
FEDERAL TAKEOVER OF CHILD CARE,
SO THEY CAN CONTROL THE
CURRICULUM AND A GREEN NEW
DEAL AND THAT’S WHY WE HAVEN’T
BEEN ABLE TO COME TOGETHER.
BRIAN:  WELL WE ALL KNOW WHY IT
TELLS YOU --
>> BUT IF I SEE A REAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, I AM MOST
OF MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
WE’LL POUNCE ON IT LIKE A NINJA.
WE JUST HADN’T SEEN ONE YET.
BRIAN:  YOU’RE AT 600 BILLION
YOU’LL GO UP A LITTLE I’M SURE
BUT NOT WHEN YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR
ELDER CARE, SCHOOL LUNCHES
AS WELL AS PRESCHOOL, AND YOU
GOT TO MILITARIZE THE IRS TO GO
RAID AND FIND SOME WAY TO GET
MORE MONEY OUT OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND CONTINUE THAT
VILLIFICATION PROCESS.
MY SENSE IS, WITH INFLATION,
WITH EVERY SINGLE THING THAT WE
BUY AND USE, NOW DOUBLING IN
PRICE FROM GAS TO LUMBER, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE OKAY WITH THIS ,
MAYBE THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN OKAY
WITH IT THREE MONTHS AGO, BUT
NOT NOW.
DON’T YOU THINK THAT THERE’S A
SENSE OUT THERE THAT THINGS
GETTING OUT OF CONTROL WITH THE
SPENDING?
>> WELL, THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
IS SPENDING MONEY LIKE A SAILOR
ONSHORE LEAVE.
IN FACT THERE’S A BILL SENATOR
SCHUMER HAS A BILL IN FRONT OF
THE SENATE RIGHT NOW THAT’S
GOING TO COST PROBABLY
$250 BILLION AND HE SAYS WE NEED
IT.
IT’S BACKED BY THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE, TO FIGHT COMMUNISM AND
MAKE US MORE COMPETITIVE AND
IT’S PROBABLY GOING TO PASS
BECAUSE SOME OF MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES HAVE SWAPPED BRAINS
WITH THE DEMOCRATS AND THEY ARE
GOING TO VOTE FOR IT.
THEY WANT TO GIVE $60 BILLION TO
BIG TECH.
NOW WE ALL KNOW BIG TECH IS
BROKE.
THEY WANT TO GIVE $60 BILLION,
THAT’S 3 BILLION A COMPANY, TO
BIG TECH SO THEY CAN MAKE A
BETTER ALGORITHM TO MORE QUICKLY
SENSOR US.
I MEAN, IT MAKES NO SENSE.
BRIAN:  LIKE THEY AGREED TO DO
WITH CHINA.
>> YEAH.
AINSLEY: AND BIDEN, HE RAN ON
THAT STUDENT LOAN FORGIVENESS
BUT IT’S NOT IN HIS LATEST, HIS
UPCOMING BUDGET.
HE TOLD THE NEW YORK TIMES, THE
IDEA YOU GO TO PENN FOR
70,000 A YEAR AND
THE PUBLIC SHOULD PAY FOR THAT I
DON’T AGREE, BUT HE RAN ON THAT.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THIS TELL THE
42 MILLION AMERICANS THAT
WERE GOING TO GET $10,000 LOBBED
OFF THEIR
STUDENT LOANS, MANY WENT TO THE
POLLS TO VOTE FOR HIM AND HE’S
NOT FULFILLING THAT PROMISE.
>> WELL I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE
IS BEING REALISTIC.
THEY DON’T HAVE THE VOTES TO
PASS IT NUMBER ONE, AND NUMBER
TWO, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON’T
SUPPORT IT.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY ALL LOANS
DON’T MATTER.
WHY STUDENT DEBT, WHY NOT CREDIT
CARD DEBT?
WHY NOT CAR LOANS.
AINSLEY: THAT’S NEXT.
>> AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
ASKED, HE WAS ASKING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, MANY OF
WHOM DIDN’T GO TO COLLEGE, TO
PAY FOR THOSE WHO DID GO, AND
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ALREADY PAID OFF THEIR STUDENT
LOANS?
BRIAN:  TRUE.
>> HERE IS WHAT OUR POLICY ON
STUDENT DEBT OUGHT TO BE.
NUMBER ONE, YOU BORROWED MONEY.
NUMBER TWO, PAY IT BACK.
PROBLEM SOLVED.
BRIAN:  RIGHT.
STEVE: IT’S THAT EASY.
SENATOR, ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
SPEND A LITTLE OF OUR MONDAY
MORNINGS WITH YOU, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY FROM